pardon pour commencer de ne pas avoir eu
le temps de voir votre film je le
regrette vous êtes vilain vous nous avez
fait des frayeurs vous êtes arrivés tard
mais vous êtes vilain dans ce film et
est-ce que ce ne serait pas par hasard
un tout petit peu je dis un poil
autobiographique non pas du tout non
Catherine fro qui est parî-il est une
formidable partenaire pour vous comment
est-ce que vous avez pu faire j'allais
dire pour être et le partenaire devant
la caméra et en même temps le
réalisateur donc derrière la caméra
payer tout simplement il y avait pas une
envie artistique de création non moi je
mérite mon salaire ce qui'est pas votre
cas si voyez pas les films mais non j'ai
pas vu le film je vous ai dit parce que
je vous en ai demandé pardon
publiquement euh tout simplement parce
que j'ai pas parce que j'ai un métier
justement moi
aussi Pontel et voilà qui pas faire c
fais des films et euh voilà et j' non
mais c'est votre boulot de voir les
films avant d'inviter les gens très bien
oui oui ou ou je vous remercie je vous
remercie infiniment votre accueil merci
beaucoup bonne soirée à vous ben bonne
soirée à vous aussi et merci